sensation sensations le mag
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
sensation en partenariat avec tv 60,18
je reçois aujourd'hui bertrand houillon
maire de magny les hameaux bonjour
bonjour or bertrand guillon l'actualité
ne nous a pas échappé en afghanistan
alors que les talibans ont pris le
pouvoir le 15 août dernier on se
souvient des images de centaines
d'afghans sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
certains s'accrocher aux avions de l'us
airforce pour échapper pour s'échapper
du pays qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti
en voyant ces images
une consternation et puis
c'est des images horribles convoi alors
on peut toujours se dire c'est à l'autre
bout du monde mais d une telle désespoir
et puis on sait ce que sont les talibans
par rapport à la privation de liberté
par rapport
à la privation dignité humaine par
rapport au risque de mort aussi qu'il y
a
humaine c'est des gens qui sont ceux
plus aucun espoir et qui cherche à fuir
leur pays par tous moyens et le seul
moyen qui restait était ce fameux
aéroports
aux mains
forces dites alliés surtout des
américains et il voit ce que ça peut
donner quand on est totalement
désespérée et encore une fois c'est
l'humain en fait emmanuel macron a
rapidement décidé d'offrir un
échappatoire pour les ressortissants
mais aussi pour les afghans et afghanes
qui ont travaillé avec la france et les
autres pays dans la lutte contre les
talibans que pensez-vous des décisions
du président de la république le droit
d'asile ne peut pas être un tri on ne
peut pas considérer qu'on va sauver des
bons et laisser les autres qu'on ne peut
pas considérer qu'on doit qu'on va
sauver des personnes qui ont pu nous
aider en échange finalement on leur
octroie le droit d'asile on peut pas non
plus faire un tri en fonction
de la possibilité d'argent aussi qu'on
peut avoir pour passer à tel endroit
le droit d'asile c'est un droit humain
des droits fondamentaux et on doit être
en capacité d'aider toute personne qui
veut fuir un régime dans lequel au pire
ils seront morts dans les prochains mois
ou années et au mieux ils auront perdu
toute dignité est alors en ayant
travaillé avec avec les alliés les
afghans et afghanes peuvent aujourd'hui
le payer de leur vie il ya également
cette notion de droits des femmes
bafouées voire même inexistant un pour
aller pour aller plus loin depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans il est
essentiel de leur venir en aide et de
leur proposer une sécurité
c'est totalement essentiel de pouvoir
les aider à sortir de ce pays est
presque pour pouvoir lutter de
l'extérieur pour reprendre leurs droits
de liberté d'égalité et finalement c'est
notre fraternité qui doit aider à tout
ça c'est un rôle encore une fois
totalement humain je vais prendre un
exemple est qui et qui est assez
flagrant parce que dans le monde du vélo
par exemple il y à un certain nombre de
femmes afghanes qui ont développé la
pratique du vélo là bas pour les femmes
et aujourd'hui elles ont brûlé leurs
affaires le cash leur matériel
pour éviter d'être prise à partie par
les talibans puisque forcément la
pratique du vélo c'est un outil de
mobilité est donc un outil de liberté
pour les femmes qui leur est totalement
interdit et on est toujours dans cette
dans cette notion aussi de dignité parce
que ça faisait partie aussi peut-être
d'une part de leur dignité de faire du
vélo de faire du sport finalement de
faire du sport de pouvoir partir de chez
elle de manière libre seul aussi sur sur
leurs bicyclettes et
bellevue voilà c'est un objet de
découverte aussi
et elle avait vraiment développer cette
pratique mais dans tous les domaines on
retrouve ces difficultés en terme de
liberté de la presse en termes de
liberté au niveau des avocats de la
justice les militants des droits de
l'homme sont aussi pour chasser là bas
on entend parler de journalistes qui
sont cachés dans leur cave tout ça
aujourd'hui il faut bien se dire que
les talibans dix ans n'ont pas changé
c'est un faux discours de se dire ça de
se dire que il faut développer où il
faut espérer que on puisse normalisé des
des relations diplomatiques non il faut
lutter contre ce type de régime est la
meilleure façon de lutter contre ce type
de régime c'est d'accueillir les
personnes qui luttent contre eux alors
justement vous êtes exprimé auprès du
parisien concernant la situation des
avenants et afghanes en danger pour vous
il est impératif de mettre en sécurité
toutes ces vies est-ce que vous avez un
projet en tête alors on s'est mis à
disposition puisque c'est la
responsabilité de l'état et
dès que j'ai su que les talibans étaient
en train de prendre le pouvoir et qu'il
y aurait forcément des personnes qui
chercheraient à fuir ce régime
pour leur liberté mais aussi pour leur
vie en fait tout simplement
j'ai signalé auprès de l'état donc via
le préfet que la commune de magny les
hameaux et est prête à aider autant que
possible pour l'accueil de ces réfugiés
il ya plusieurs façons d'aider de
l'hébergement de des dons de matériels
de vêtements de l'accompagnement aussi
pour accompagner sur les droits par
exemple
ça tout ça ça s'est déjà fait par le par
le passé sur la commune de magny les
hameaux
et je crois à cet élan de fraternité
cette solidarité qui existe sur notre
commune on peut continuer la mettre en
place alors
l'état m'a répondu puisque j'ai eu une
rencontre avec le préfet à l'égalité des
chances et
l'état n'est pas forcément le mieux à
même pour faire l'accueil chez
l'habitant et pour accompagner de
l'accueil chez l'habitant par contre il
ya d'autres possibilités
on en a discuté ensemble mais on fera
aussi en lien avec nos associations le
nécessaire pour pouvoir accompagner au
mieux car justement à votre objectif
aujourd'hui c'est d'accueillir les
réfugiés au sein de votre commune magny
les hameaux al'inverse des grandes
villes ne possède pas de centres
d'hébergement d'urgence comment est ce
que vous comptez vous y prendre vous
avez dit c'est l'accueil chez l'habitant
qui va à qui va primer on avait fait en
2015 cet appel
au moment de la vague de réfugiés
syriens notamment et un certain nombre
d'habitants s'étaient proposés à
l'époque l'état n'avait pas répondu
puisque justement la capacité de l'état
était de pouvoir accueillir dans des
plus grands centres d'hébergement mais
finalement par le biais de réseaux
associatifs il a été possible au fur et
à mesure d'accueillir quelques familles
ou ou des individus syriens ou même
d'autres d'autres populations des
tibétains notamment est alors invité sur
la matinale le 20 août dernier julien
odoul qui fait parti du rassemblement
national s'est positionné contre
l'accueil des familles afghanes en
france il a souligné un manque de
sécurité pour le peuple français pendant
ce pensant que le flux migratoire sert
finalement aux terroristes pour venir en
france et a évoqué un choc des cultures
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces propos
le problème de sécurité c'est fasciste
est clairement c'est à dire que à
vouloir jouer sur les peurs à vouloir
diviser au maximum finalement ils font
le même jeu que les taliban il est exclu
au lieu d'inclure au maximum et au lieu
de travailler sur
les droits humains de manière générale à
vouloir exclure il prive de liberté des
personnes à vouloir exclure il conforte
des inégalités et finalement ils ne sont
pas fraternelle et finalement ils ne
respectent pas les valeurs républicaines
et alors partout en france différentes
associations veulent que le gouvernement
mette en place un visa spécial pour les
familles qui fuient l'afghanistan est ce
que c'est une idée que vous partagez
aussi aujourd'hui on sait que un certain
nombre de familles sont séparées puisque
certaines personnes sont arrivées en
france le reste de la famille est encore
là bas il faut absolument qu'on puisse
les réunir
visa spécial ou autres de toute façon
c'est notre responsabilité la grande
difficulté qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est
que le point aérien est fermé et il va
falloir trouver d'autres moyens de
pouvoir exfiltré un certain nombre de
personnes qui encore une fois risquent
leurs vies aujourd'hui mais toujours
dans l'idée importante de ne pas
abandonner justement les afghanistan on
va revenir sur l'accueil chez l'habitant
que vous proposez
vous l'aviez dit un des habitants l'ont
déjà fait en déjà accueilli des réfugiés
est ce que vous avez eu des retours
justement de leur part évidemment il n'y
a aucune difficulté sur l'accueil à
partir du moment où il ya une
bienveillance puisque on accueille des
personnes qui ont vécu des atrocités qui
ont fui en laissant toute leur vie
finalement et tout leur identité
derrière eux donc il faut les
accompagner pour se reconstruire
se calmer et tranquilliser et ensuite
refaire leur vie et les habitants que
j'ai l'occasion de rencontrer
régulièrement qu'ils ont eue accueillir
des séries 1 des tibétains
et d'autres populations
aujourd'hui sont prêtes à accueillir des
personnes qui venaient qui viennent
d'afghanistan
il n'y a aucune difficulté à partir du
moment où on est en bienveillance est
tout simplement entre humains il faut
savoir que les personnes qui fuient ces
pays là ils choisissent pas de partir ce
n'est pas une immigration choisie
ils fuient par rapport à une
problématique qui est une problématique
est vital pour
de pouvoir finalement les accueillir et
les réconforter
du côté humain c'est leur montrer qu'il
ya un espoir quelque part et ont retiré
on retiendra surtout la bienveillance
dont vous faites preuve en tant que les
eaux en tant que maire de magny les
hameaux merci beaucoup bertrand guillon
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensations et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez vous sur notre site et
applications radio sensations
le